forgive me Father I have seen but I  think I'm not sure  so it's buckets I just like him better  than I like human need and I have found  that I can understand now what they're  saying I guess it was because when I was  young I found it very difficult to talk  to girls and then this ginger cat who  was a girl came along and I just found I  could I could talk to her  Taylor Swift I met her on a TV show and  she won't mind a bit okay but I felt bad  for her because she has this stupid  looking cat you know let's be as folded  down I thought I thought this isn't fair  she's a lovely loved because she  deserves a proper cap and I'm thinking  oh let me buying a proper cap and then  just sort of delivering it to her under  she's not there you know said she comes  back she sees  oh it's you